hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play black
snow I know it's been far too long since
I got back this in all reality it's only
been a few days but I mean it's been a
while so I need to finish this up so
this is going to be the last episode no
matter what I'm not stopping until I
beat this and you guys have explicitly
told me that I need to go back to the
gym and break like a block by the door
or something or there's there's like
doors locked and then you guys said that
there was something else in this room
that I needed to see but I can't quite
see cuz it's so dirt but there's
something ha ha ah that was like 10
bajillion times of obvious how did I not
see that alright whatever okay so that
not sure what that is whistling wind I
guess okay so here's ah ha I got the key
out of the what ha ha what I don't I'm
not exactly sure what was going on there
the key was in a block of a cinder block
something I don't even know how this got
here anyway so someone didn't want me to
leave but good thing I had that hammer
and chisel which means that I only need
to find the navigational map and the
snow cat tread Lincoln you guys also
said that the majority of the game
remain to be in in the written in this
in the main complex as opposed to
anywhere else so I need to be able to
find the other stuff I'm just double
checking to make sure that I got
everything here okay now T's unlocked
and then I will move on accordingly wait
a minute isn't that the code that's the
code from Portal to make a cake yeah to
package chocolaty cake mix don't know
how I recognized that but yeah that's
definitely one one empty spoon salt
that's that's a that's that's that's the
cake mix that's the cake MCOs back from
portal 1 when you know she was obsessed
with cake and all that jazz all right so
anyway moving on I need to find the
navigational maps and the bloody bloody
the bleedin bloody snow cat tread link I
don't even know where without me okay
Alex suitor a--the see
methinks I remember there was a computer
somewhere around here that had a
super-special lockness to it and it
might have just had something that I
need but then again maybe not maybe I'm
wrong I've been wrong before let us save
nope uh-uh
hello hi hello ladies see here the
window no I'm backtracking a bit here
maybe I should have been more paid a
little more attention when you guys were
telling me what to do
I don't pay attention ever ever uh okay
yeah this computer this was the one yeah
remember this one so maybe then yeah
it's locked but I don't I do not
hey let me go back in it I do not have
the password there's got to be a way to
unlock this all right I got no no way
into that alright so as you guys have
told me there must be something else
that I need and you guys said that it
was majorly in this area here whoo buddy
howdy because I was deliriously sick hmm
check this one I believe I did a long
time ago
let's see Liz
all right I see all nice picture okay
sitting Indian artist looted what's that
what did I just do I don't know what is
going on anymore one minute feels so
long I think I am the last one shouldn't
have eaten those open rations not
feeling so well I think I'm gonna like
and now you're dead okay what is the
synchronisation of the scuba clabon sink
I think it tied to my hand held no it's
like failure I don't know okay I guess
there's nothing that I must have missed
something something that you guys are
now thinking that I am a giant idiot ah
I'm not stupid I'm not I'm not stupid I
am smart
I am smart I've fired what's in here ah
[ __ ] come on you ain't gonna give a [ __ ]
oh it's down on the ground
ah God ah bah oh wait there's the door
over there huh ah open up open up there
we go okay so I found this room I don't
know what it is
nothing okay that's nothing where is
this the hell am I now I this window
open what am I doing with my life
oh yeah nothing okay that's really I
really wish I had a flashlight of some
sort I'm I'm just not supposed to have a
flashlight this entire game is there
nothing nothing for me oh boy ah gah gah
gah balls oh you asked bag Jesus piece
of x-ray film in a stewpot ha what's in
there darkness good
I like darkness that's my favorite
all right whatever here we go into the
darkness oh I heard Stephie step up oh
just a blackness uh-huh okay there's
lots of blackness over there pyrotechnic
Locker give me more of those give me one
that go
there that's locked that's down
there's blackness but I'll leap over it
yeah now what's going on
what's going on I can't see Oh I'm gonna
run out of juice I'm gonna run out of
juice ah it's like a maze oh god it's
running out he's running out of running
out of my time in a time that I am gonna
die I'm gonna die ha ha ha I made it
hello lady
now I stir you ha ha ha this is a
mistake this was a mistake
ha ha well now I know where to go oh man
oh man this isn't fair this isn't fair
what do you expect from me what do you
expect from me I don't know what do you
want now ow ow ow ow ow sounds like a
seagull can be give me a gimme gimme you
who's there anything over here Oh
pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow
aha how many do I need ah not come on
sounds like a seagull I swear okay oh
and now everything's gone pastel fudge
ah how do I get my health back give me
health back
give me my health health give to me
ah no that's the opposite of why I
wanted thank you is there something in
the darkness no nothing of the darkness
great fantastic
everything's darker now that it's black
and white fudge
how am I supposed to get there I have no
life I have no life I have no life
this is a problem you see how this is a
problem Oh God all right kill me
tell me buddy kill me bring it bring
your a news how been hurt
oh no go away wait a minute oh okay
usually dancing a minute
da bla bla bla server is there a health
thing in here is there some point on me
being here while still being alive I
have a feeling I was supposed to grab
some pyrotechnic jumbo tell me okay
hopefully my relay have me some help
what
all righty then
hahaha okie dokie
alright so if I go ah bollocks bollocks
I'm gonna oh I'm gonna I'm gonna oh oh
you suck on that go over here hop where
are you what you Cal huh
where'd you go man what'd you go scare
do this this soda machine I would be too
ha ha bro dodge ha ha oh and
everything's going black and white watch
everything just yep faded to black and
white good good good good good good
my favorite that's my favorite when that
happens I love it
ha ha what's this then ah ha piece of
x-ray film give me what is this command
execute div dee dee if dev random of dev
SDA or dee dee if dev zero of dev sta
okay I don't know I don't know what that
does
hang on wait maybe I press the wrong
button
I can't type anything I can't do
anything no okay so hey camera I go okay
so I got the last piece of x-ray film oh
damn it daba daba 'let get out of there
tablet and I'm still pastel okay no
heater I heard footsteps and it just has
to be pitch black out there was there
supposed to be some sort of a you know
light ah come on
balls I have a feeling that somewhere
I'm supposed to turn on a light but I
don't know boop-boo-boo-boop up up up up
okay that's it no ooh here we go what's
this then this is nothing this nothing
is it okay so if I find one last piece
of the x-ray I've gotten three so far
I'm assuming at four would bring me up
to the necessary number that I need
maybe possibly it could be it could be
just that aha
what's this they say whoa Wow [ __ ] what
I think I'm already pretty thoroughly
infected boy if I had colors I could see
what was going on here yeah what is that
it looks gross
whoever it is actually it sounds gross
don't eat her own I can't see a ding
damn thing ow ow oh it's gross it's
goopy what's hey is that for I should be
for right I'd love to get some health
back maybe he'll oh it's a giant uvula
the uvula is a thing in the back of your
throat
well alright that did one for me ah okay
so that's four I'm assuming that the
code to the door is four digits so uh
where do I assemble these here x-rays
and I put them on like a shiny surface
Oh GRU you vitals oh come on Raj okay
nothing there that doesn't help me
I might just I might just you know
reload my save hang on
cuz I mean done the doors are against me
everything's against me why why does
everything hate me so much
I is everything I hate me spread the
love man just a little bit it'd be nice
okay there's definitely nothing I'm
assuming there's something that I need
to put this on the x-rays for who knows
I don't you know I do not I bet you do
what's this it's all that's done use my
hammer to break it these aren't the
hammers that I'm talking about struck a
hammer however it - anybody I hope
people know that reference cuz I'm not
just knocking okay I gotta find
somewhere to put these some white
translucent surface as to which I can I
might have to go through there again up
not proton off products products but ah
oh my god
I didn't see where I came in where the
heck did I come in I don't know where to
put these dings I don't know I don't
know anyway him it that's locked
nevermind
boy it sure would be nice to be able to
see that would be lovely but alas my
life is a living hell maybe if I can
know I'm locked in here with the that
gate shut oh maybe there's something in
here huh yeah goop in my eyeballs ah no
more good that more get some weird goop
touching the ground
yep goop goop goop goop blue suit goop
out that was useless
ha ha ha come on where's where did I
come in from where's the ding dong I
didn't even see where I came in from
what what what I still don't make any
sense this doesn't make any sense and
did other people take this long to meet
the game because am I just not big of a
[ __ ]
I am RA okay there's gotta be something
and I'm just ding dong damn missing Oh
Papa butter butter butter butter boo boo
doo doo boop boop boop I bet I bet that
thing whatever it is I'm missing is
something that I would be able to see
with my eyeballs if if oh wait what's
this uh-huh
this um can you open up please what's
this
what's all this done aha of course ah I
would have been able to see that very
easily wait what
okay wait hang on companion that looks
like a dog or something so I guess
second wind lungs I'm guessing
enlightenment brain accusing you point
your finger conquer worm it's more than
your dusted companion that looks like a
dog second win lungs
all right so four four nine one seven
four four nine one seven let's see if I
can get back probably nod four four nine
one seven four four nine months of work
will whoo-whoo oh four four nine one
seven four four nine one seven four four
four nine one seven ah
gasps no no oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh no no no no no okay try it again
can't see anything I would have seen the
right way to go if I had help
yeah you see how that would have
happened doc no does wrong album that
was the wrong choice
there was a right choice and I've so far
made two wrong choices in a place where
the answer is probably extremely obvious
if I could see it for Jack Ann what what
oh there oh there ah made it
hey you stand right there dick good joke
on yourself all right
whoo hello okay so uh this is a
navigational map I'm sorry
ah no oh
what does
how did I survive wait wha oh holy crap
okay I did not see that coming I'm I'm
dead fears I didn't see that coming no
one told me that was gonna happen
ha ha ha ha no I was gonna survive
actually if a guy like me got trapped in
this I would probably dead I wouldn't
even be get a chance like he had to try
and escape I would be dead with the rest
of them I would be gone
no one should count on me an emergency
situation cuz obviously I don't do too
well there are no reloads in in real
life there's no respawned out there
I heard the graphics are great but if
you get lag out there ok so anyway haha
oh man that was awesome that really was
I mean II D I mean that was really
really really well-made game I mean I
was really annoying sometimes with you
know your health going down low and it
getting black and white and then it just
made it more difficult the entire time
because you couldn't do anything about
and you couldn't see but other than that
it was a great game I've great respect
for the developers I'm just bad at these
games I'm actually good at games I just
want them when I'm on what people are
watching me and I'm pressured and
there's like if I don't have time to
figure it out for myself and I got a
talk use brain power
I'm governing like 90 percent of my
brain power to my talking centers me I'm
smart obviously okay so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
or in the box